What I'd like to do next is describe a different algorithm
that I learned under the name "Russian Peasant's Algorithm."
If you'd like to learn more about it, you can go to the Wikipedia page
called "Ancient Egyptian Multiplication."
This is an algorithm that people actually implemented by hand before there were computers.
Here's the Russian Peasants Algorithm in Python.
You can see it follows pretty closely along with the naive algorithm that I described before.
It starts off assigning a and b to x and y.
It starts off z as an accumulator set to 0.
It's going to repeat while x is bigger than 0 a bunch of steps
that involve accumulating values in z and making x smaller.
What makes this algorithm work really well is when doubling
and halving numbers is really easy to do.
If you're not familiar with this syntax, this is saying take whatever the binary representation
of y is and shift it over 1 to the left.
This is saying take whatever the binary representation of x is and shift it over to the right.
Let's do a little quiz to see if you know what that would do.
A straightforward question--what is 17>>1 in Python?
171, 9, 8, 8.5, or 34?